so the la lakers beat the miami heat to
win the nba title on sunday night
very few people saw this only about five
and a half million
those are the lowest ratings in the
history of the nba
by comparison 18.34 million
people watched game six of last year's
nba finals and 11.4 million people
watched the regular season nfl game on
sunday night
so why is this happening it is a
collapse it's a disaster
why well the nba more than any other
sports league has completely embraced
politics people who dislike this country
and the chinese communist party
the league even printed the word black
lives matter on all of their courts
like all corporate activism it's
fraudulent people know that
nba owners will complain about police
brutality but they cannot bring
themselves to condemn
say the slavery underway right now
in china watch when it comes to human
rights i'm against all human rights
violations around the world
china including the ones in china china
is not the only country with human
rights violations
do you condemn the genocide that's going
on right now in china
all human rights violations why can't
you be specific
yes because the way proclamations work
in this country
the minute you say them anywhere you're
going to use this as a headline
cuban says this this and this what's
wrong with that headline cubing condemns
ethnically because i got to deal with
the troll but then why would why would
the nba take 500 million dollars plus
from a country that is engaging in
ethnic cleansing
why would so basically you're saying
that no
nobody should do business with china
ever they are a customer they're
they are a customer of ours and guess
what megan i'm okay with doing business
with china
yeah mark cuban condemns ethnic
cleansing who'd want that headline the
pr people would go crazy
that was mark cuban of course who owns
the dallas mavericks it was also a moral
coward i guess we didn't know that
in that clip he sounded a little bit
like joe biden can't say anything could
be the headline
are viewers ever going to go back to the
nba
jason willock has thought a lot about
this he writes for and helps run
outkick.com and we're happy to have them
on tonight jason thanks for coming on so
first just
since you've covered this for decades
perspective on the numbers on the
viewership
are these numbers as bad as they seem
yeah they're
really bad uh tucker and there's no way
to clean them up
because and i know they're competing
against the nfl
they're not playing during their normal
time slot
but they have lebron james who is
allegedly the biggest star in all of
sports
he's playing for the lakers the biggest
star in the nba
and they couldn't draw flies this is a
problem
so uh what's the cause of it i mean i i
mean it seems
to me like there's a connection between
the aggressive politics and the league
and declining viewership but i want to
be fair and ask someone who follows it
for a living
it's multifaceted look obviously kovitz
had a
issue but there's no denying
that this hard lean into
an anti-american sentiment has
turned off traditional sports fans just
think about the way sports have sold
themselves
for more than a hundred years or close
uh ever since jesse owens 1936 olympic
american sports have been the ambassador
for americana
we played the national anthem it's a
patriotic event
this is a total 180 in terms of branding
and the way the nba has presented itself
and a lot of people are just
disconcerted by
we used an analogy today on out kick in
a very
outstanding piece about what's going on
with the nba just think of disney world
where they play these games
instead of mickey mouse as their brand
ambassador
cardi b was their brand ambassador
suppose
a who uh women dressed in hooters
outfits
were strapping mom and dad and their
teenage kids
into space mountain that would be quite
a brand change and would be off-putting
to the traditional disney world customer
base
that's what's gone on here in the nba
though it wouldn't shock me if disney
went there
so you must know mark cuban everybody
knows mark cube i know mark cuban he's
not stupid
didn't think he was stupid until that
megyn kelly interview why wouldn't he
just say yeah of course i'm against
ethnic cleansing in china why is that so
hard
because china
is there number one market that the nba
is interested in
america is not the nba's priority
china is and that's why and
tucker i'm not very political at all i'm
just not but right
president trump's america first agenda
this is what he's talking about american
companies the nba
being hijacked by foreign influence
this is what's happening to our country
i'm so glad it's being exposed in the
nba because it's an opportunity to
educate the average american sports band
or whatever
so you can finally understand what this
foreign
influence is doing to our country
they've turned
a patriotic cultural event
into an anti-american protest in the nba
and to some degree the nfl we've got to
put a stop to this
well especially since as as you're
describing it they're doing it
for the benefit of china our chief rival
on the world stage i mean
that seems really sinister to me it's
look there china has 1.4 billion
citizens
china is spending a lot of money
trying to undermine america and american
culture
this is what communist run countries do
they smear the west
in america as racist meanwhile
they are 1 000 times more racist than
america
1 000 times exactly yeah this is a pet
issue for me
a major issue for me because there was a
i played football at ball state i'm a
supporter of the school
we had a young man arrested black young
man former football player
arrested in china on some bogus charges
spent three years
inside a chinese prison costs me and
others money to get him home
it this whole thing of like hey we can't
say anything about china
but we're gonna blast america
it's hip it's hypocritical it's
dangerous
it's it's treasonous and it needs to
stop
i'm going to look up that ball state
story i had never heard that wendell
brown
i'll look it up jason whitlock thanks so
much for that